حاله من الغليان تعيش اسرائيل حول
التغييرات القضائيه واقاله وزير الدفاع
في اخر التطورات لا تزال حشود المتظاهرين
تملا الساحات في القدس ورملا فضلا عن تل
ابيب صاحبها محاولات من الشرطه لمنع
المتظاهرين زعيم المعارضه في كلمه القاها
وسط المتظاهرين على عدم التراجع قبل ان
يكون لاسرائيل دستور مكتوب على حد دق على
حد قوله ومن جهته دعا رئيس الوزراء بنمينه
المتظاهرين في القدس الى تجنب العنف في
وقت نصح فيه بعض المستشارين نتنياهو
بتاجيل خطابه حتى معرفه حجم التظاهرات
الليله مراسله العربيه فادت بانما نتنياهو
قد يؤجل خطابه الى اجل غير مسمر
قبل ذلك بحسب تصريحات نقلتها وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه قال رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو انه يواجه حمله دعائيه سلبيه ضد
التعديلات القضائيه التي يتجه لتعليقها
واشار الى ان المحتجين وطنيون لكنهم لا
يفهمون لاصلاح الذي يدعو اليه وذكرت قناه
12 الاسرائيليه ان مقربين من نتنياهو
نصحوه بالتعجيل بخطاب لتهدئه الشارع
في تراجع المفاجئ اكد وزير العدل
الاسرائيلي يريف ليفين انه سيحترم اي قرار
يتخذ رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو بشان
مستقبل التعديلات القضائيه مضيفا بان
الافتقار الى الوحده في الحكومه يمكن ان
يطيح بها وقال ليفين في بيان له انه اقتنع
بامكانيه تعليق التعديلات الدستوريه مشيرا
الى ان اصرار كل فرد في الحكومه على موقفه
سيؤدي الى اسقاطها وانهيار الائتلاف
الحاكم
[تصفيق]
وقد طلب حزب العمل المعارض في اسرائيل بحل
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي متهما حكومه رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو بانها جعلت
الكنيسه رهينه لخطتها المتطرفه
طالب حزب العمل المعارض بوقف ما سماه جنون
حكومه نتنياهو في اشاره الى التعديلات
القضائيه
افادت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه بان الحكومه
الائتلافيه التي يتزعمها رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي باليمين نتنياهو نجت من اقتراح
بسحب الثقه قدمته المعارضه احتجاجا على
خطه الاصلاح القضائي حيث اعلن رئيس
الكنيست ان المقترح رفض باغلبيه 59 صوتا
مقابل موافقه 53 ومن جهه اخرى فهذا مراسل
العربيه بوقوع اشتباكات بين الامن ومحتجين
وسطت تل ابيب واغلاق العديد من الطرق
الرئيسيه
وقد ابارت رساله لنقابه العاملين في وزاره
الخارجات الاسرائيليه ان السفارات في
انحاء العالم تلقت تعليمات بالانضمام الى
اضراب اليوم الاثنين ضد خطه التعديلات
القضائيه لرئيس الوزراء بنيامين التانيان
واشارت رساله الى انشطه وزاره الخارجيه في
اسرائيل وخارجها ستكتصر على خدمه الطوارئ
فقط
[موسيقى]
من الناصره في فلسطين ينضم الينا المحلل
السياسي النظير مجلي السيد نظير مرحبا بك
معنا هل يستطيع
سيد نظير بن يمينه في خطابه المرتقب
ان يعالج المشكله
عميقه جدا التي تعاني منها اسرائيل هذه
الايام
مساء الخير لك عزيزي وللاخوه المشاهدين
والمشاهدات لا ليس سهلا على ان يواجه هذه
المشكله ولن ياتي بحلول الجذريه وسيحاول
ان يؤجل
التشريعات لانه محكوم بايدي
حلفائه الذين عقد صفقه معهم هم يدعمونه في
مواجهه قضيه الفساد التي يحاكم فيها في
المحكمه المركزيه في القدس وهو يدعم القطط
التي ياتون بها لتغيير منظومه الحكم في
اسرائيل وليس فقط اصلاحات القضاء ولذلك هو
محكوم بهذه الرغبه لكن ما وجهه الاحتجاز
غير المتوقعه التي
صارت في الشارع خلال كل هذه الاسابيع 12
اسبوعا على التوالي
والانفجار الذي حصل امس بعدما اعلن
نتنياهو عن اقاله
يعجلانت او نيته اقالته لم يقله بعد حتى
الان ولكن عن يده اقالته خرجت الجماهير
بشكل عطني في مختلف الاماكن 150 الف ان
امضوا كل هذه الليله في الشوارع احتجاجا
على هذه الخطوه فهذا هز داخل اللكود من
داخله واصبح هناك ضغط على نتنيه وليس فقط
من الشارع بل من داخل حزب هنالك من بدا
يتمرد ويؤيد ضد نتنياهو هذا الامر جعله
يحاول ان يؤجل لكن بالمقابل هبه
الاحتجاجيه هي هبه قويه تعبر عن الدوله
العميقه في المجتمع الاسرائيلي التي تصر
على فرد اجده ثانيه لم يعودوا يكتفوا لا
بالتجميد الخطه
يمكن ان تتجه الازمه في سيناريوهاتها سيد
نظير بالنسبه للشارع المحتج
الى اي مدى يمكن ان يصل ما السقف يعني
الذي يمكن ان يطالب به في هذه الاحتجاجات
وهل سيكتفي
باي موقف للحكومه او نتنياهو ام سيصاعد
وماذا عن موقف بنيامين نتنياهو يعني
وحكومته كيف يمكن النظر الى مجمل هذه
الاوضاع
الموجه الاحتجاج وقاده الاحتجاج الذين
يختلفون عن القياده السياسيه المعارضه في
اسرائيل
لديهم موقف مبدئي لن نكتفي بشطب هذه القطه
الان نريد الدستورا يضمن لنا ان لا تاتي
حكومه غدا او بعد غد وتغير القوانين فهم
يريدون دستور هذا الطلب لم يكن يتبناه احد
في المعارضه الاسرائيليه يعني يهير نقيد
كان يتحدث عن امكانيات حوار الان مثل ما
تفضلتم في تقريركم بالمقدمه يتحدث عن
دستور لاول مره لان قياده احتجاج افترضت
على لقيت وفرضت على جانس ان يطرحها قضيه
الدستور وهذا يعني ان الامور من جهه
المحتجين لن تنتهي ولن تتوقف عند اي حد
السقف مفتوح وهم يقولون انهم سيواصلون
حمله الاحتجاج حتى لو استمرت اربع سنوات
عندما تسقط الحكومه وطبعا هم سيحاول ان
تسقط الحكومه قبل ذلك لاننا نتحدث عن قوه
كبيره في المجتمع الاسرائيلي نتحدث عن
الجيش ونتحدث عن الشرطه والمخابرات
والمؤسسه القضائيه والمؤسسه الاقتصاديه
رجال الاعمال النقابات ان نتحدث عن
المؤسسه الاكاديميه نتحدث عن صناعه
الهايتيك كل هذه القوه تملك مفاتيح اساسيه
في المجتمع الاسرائيلي لذلك انا اسميها
الدوله العميقه وهي تقف موحده ضد هذه
الحكومه واجراءاتها لانها تعرف ان هذه
الحكومه جاءت لتحدث هذا التغيير الجوهري
في نظام الحكم في اسرائيل وهذه مساله ليست
من اليوم بالمناسبه هذه يشتغلون عليها في
اليمين منذ 18 عاما
[موسيقى]
العلاقه بين نتنياهو وبين
الجيش بعد بعد اقاله غلانت
هل اهتزت هل يمكن الحديث عن شرق الان في
هذه العلاقه بين بين بين
حكومه نتنياهو بين وزاره الدفاع الجيش
الاسرائيلي
اولا هذا الشرح قائم منذ سنه 2011 وليس
اليوم عندما طلب نتنياهو خطه للهجوم على
ايران وكان الجيش غير مستعد لذلك ورفض
القطه وطالبا بميزانيات هائله لكي يستعد
لمثل هذه الحرب وعلى مدى سنوات العشر التي
تلت هذه الفتره كان نتنياهو يحرض على
الجيش وعلى قياده بالجيش كل المواقع
الاخباريه والمواقع البحثيه التي يمتلكها
اليمين في اسرائيل كانت بشكل منهجي تحارب
الجيش تتهمه بالتبذير وتتهمه بالتنازل عن
عقيده القتال والمواجهه والاقدام وغير ذلك
ولذلك كان هنالك شرخ وان نتنياهو يتهم
الجيش بانه حاول الاطاحه به في الانتخابات
الاخيره
وليس صدفه ان نجد نتنياهو يعير نتنياهو
اتهم الولايات المتحده بدعم هذه القطه
لانقلاب على حكومه نتنياهو ويتهمون الحمله
الاحتجاج الحاليه بهذا الشكل لذلك الشرق
قائم يتعمق اكثر من هم بالشارع هم يمثلون
ايضا الجيش هيئه رئاسه اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اجتمعت اليوم للبحث عن الضرر
الامني الذي تحدده تحدثه هذه القطه
وقرارات الحكومه مما يعني ان هو كبير
ولذلك من الصعب ان يتخيل المراه الان ان
يتراجع نتنياهو ويحدث مصالحه مع الجيش بعد
عشر سنوات من الدم الاسود الذي جرى بينهما
تعبير البيت الابيض عن حاله من القلق
وخشيه كذلك على تداعيات هذه الازمه على
الامن القومي بالنسبه
لاسرائيل ما هي الدلالاته سيد نبيل
اولا في الولايات المتحده توجد قوه يعني
من يحكم هو الحزب الديمقراطي وتوجد قوه
كبيره لليهود الامريكيين في هذا الحزب
وتاثير بالغ وهؤلاء يخشون على اسرائيل من
اسرائيل يعتبرون سياسه نتنياهو مدمره
للمشروع الصهيوني يخشون على الشعب اليهودي
ومستقبله من وراء هذه السياسه خصوصا وانهم
يلاحظون ان هذه السياسه جاءت لخدمه اهداف
شخصيه عندنا تنياهو الذي اقام صفقه مع قوه
اخرى لديه ايضا مصالح شبيه
وضمن التغيرات في القوانين التي ياتي بها
نتنياهو قوانين فرض قوانين شريعه يهوديه
على
وتفضيل على القوانين المدنيه هكذا يريد
حلفائه الحريدين وهذا يعني عمليا ابعاد
اليهود الامريكان عن اليهوديه بالنسبه
اليهم هم غالبيتهم اصلاحيون ولذلك يشعرون
بانهم سيفقدون انتمائهم اليهود لنتيجه
لهذه السياسي ولذلك هذا الامر يؤثر على
الاداره الامريكيه فضلا عن الرؤيه
الاستراتيجيه الامنيه الولايات المتحده
تقيم علاقات بالاساس مع المؤسسه العسكريه
الامنيه ويوجد انسجام تامه بين المؤسستين
في واشنطن وتل ابيب وهذا يصب ايضا في
المعركه التي يقودونها في مواجهه نتنياهو
للضغط وهذا فضلا عن انهم لا يحب
قد ادار حربا ضد الحزب الديمقراطي والرئيس
يذكر تماما تلك الفتره لانه كان نائبا
للرئيس واليوم يشعر بان نتنياهو اصبح عبئا
وليس عبرا مساعدا او حليفا من الممكن ان
ياخذه فعين الاعتبار في معاركه وقضاياها
شكرا جزيلا لك من الناصره المحلل السياسي
نظير المجلي
شكرا
نذكر مره اخرى بتطورات الاوضاع الميدانيه
في اسرائيل نشاهد الان في هذه الصور
المباشر
الاحتجاجات ضد التغييرات القضائيه واقاله
وزير
الدفاعات مستمره لا تزال حشود المتظاهرين
تزيد وتملا الساحات في القدس ورام الله
فضلا عن تل ابيب ايضا هناك محاولات من
الشرطه لمنع المتظاهرين كشفت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه عن 80 الف متظاهر على الاقل
يطوقون الكنيسه نذهب الى الكنيسه من امامه
تحديدا تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه لانك
الغاصي لنا مرحبا بك ما هي اخر التطورات
الحشود تستمر في التواجد في هذه الساعات
اهلا بك يعني فعليا الحشود تتزايد منذ
صباح اليوم يتوافد عشرات الالاف من مدن
مختلفه الى القدس من تل ابيب من حيفا من
بئر السبع من مناطق مختلفه قاموا باستخدام
ايضا القطارات العامه للتوجه الى القدس
والتجمع هنا كما ترون امام الكنيست يعني
ان استطاع ايضا عبد مساعدتي حتى تقومون
برؤيه اعداد كبيره من المتظاهرين الان هم
خرجوا ضد هذه التعديلات القضائيه وضد
نتنياهو حتى يعني على ما يبدو ان ايضا
هناك غضب ولكن في نفس الوقت شعور
بالانتصار من قبل هؤلاء المتظاهرين حيث
يعني باتت مطالبهم يعني
باتت مطالبهم فعليا تتجه الى التنفيذ هناك
مخاوف مخاوف كبيره في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الان ويعني محاوله لاقناع نتنياهو بالخروج
والاعلان ربما تاجيل هذه التعديلات
القضائيه ولكن المتظاهرين يقولون بانهم لن
يرضوا فقط بتاجيل هذه التعديلات القضائيه
الى ما بعد الاعياد اليهوديه او حتى بعد
استقلال اسرائيل اي بعد شهر من الان ولكن
هم يقولون نحن نريد الغاء هذه التعديلات
القضائيه بشكل نهائي لان هذه التعديلات
القضائيه من شانها ان تؤدي اسرائيل حسب ما
وصفوها يعني تعديلات الديكتاتوريه
وايضا كان هناك اضراب شامل او اضراب في
عديد من المجالات انضم عدد من الطلاب من
الجامعات ايضا من البنوك من التعليم هناك
عمال ايضا من ماكدونالدز وهو ايضا شركه
عالميه يعرفها الجميع قاموا باغلاق
متاجرهم لمده اربع ساعات في جميع انحاء
بلاد البلاد يعني نحن نتحدث ايضا الى
انضمام وكان هنا مطار بن غريون الدولي الى
هذا الاضراب ايضا نتحدث عن اضراب في
مجالات مختلفه الجامعات الاسرائيليه عدد
منها ايضا انضموا الى هذه المظاهرات